le hasard du calendrier législatif aura
voulu que nous débattions ce jour de la
prééminence des lois de la république
trois jours seulement après la
nomination de conflans sainte honorine
rendons hommage à long terme de cette
discussion là deux cent soixante
septième victime de l'islamisme depuis
2012 dans notre pays
samuel pâtit professeur
d'histoire-géographie décapité par un
islamiste tchétchène
ils ne passeront pas voici la seule
réponse de l'exécutif dans ces
circonstances de guerre quelle pitoyable
force car ils sont déjà là monsieur le
président ils sont déjà là monsieur le
ministre
dans les écoles les hôpitaux les
associations sportives culturelles et
cultuelles les entreprises les services
publics et bien sûr les partis
politiques plus aucun pan de notre
société dé préserver de ce fléau de la
division communautaire et du cancer
islamistes le communautarisme et la
lèpre de notre pays il divise il sépare
ils se moquent de la loi il la combat de
ce communautarisme est né en france une
cinquième colonne islamistes hostiles à
ce que nous sommes et déterminés à nous
à battre elle se compose de la réunion
du séparatisme d'en haut
celui des élites individualiste des élus
islamo clientéliste et indigéniste avec
un séparatisme d'en bas celui des
trafiquants des crapules et des
religieux extrémistes
on est loin très loin de la prééminence
des lois de la république
tabou parmi les tabous vous refusez
toujours de remettre en question la
politique d'immigration massive alors
que c'est au grand remplacement que nous
devons la grande fracture communautaire
dans ces conditions l'islamisme a encore
de beaux jours devant lui par le
caractère massif de l'immigration
nombreuses sont les individus qui ont
rejeté notre modèle français et qui ont
préféré conserver leurs moeurs leurs
coutumes leurs traditions aujourd'hui
les plus fanatiques d'entre eux devant
nos renoncements veulent nous imposer
d'autres lois celle de la charia vos
bougies vos drapeaux en berne vaud tout
l'été ne suffisent plus à faire oublier
que si nous en sommes là c'est à vous
que nous le devons au rassemblement
place de la république ressemble
davantage au bal des hypocrites loin de
manifester vous devriez vous terrer de
honte car si les barbus sont coupables
les ai vus
eux sont responsables nos lois bien
qu'écrite et qui ne demande qu'à être
appliquée pour abattre le monstre
islamiste ne le sont toujours pas à
raison ceux-là de votre capitulation
soin de votre collaboration
pendant ce temps l'islamiste farhi
dickens a déclaré à l'issue de son
procès mercredi dernier le site sa
chéchia le français que nous sommes chez
vous pour vous égorger quarante ans plus
tard monsieur le ministre de la justice
la peine de mort par décapitation
rétablie sur notre sol mais seulement
pour les innocents
mes chers collègues n'entendez-vous
toujours pas dans le camp dans nos
villes et dans nos campagnes agir ces
féroces soldats islamistes qui viennent
jusque dans nos bras égorger et décapité
nos fils et nos compagnes alors aux
armes aux armes sénateurs aux armes
monsieur le ministre dupont moretti aux
armes de la loi rien que la loi met
toute la loi et pour conclure et je vous
l'annoncerai chers collègues si demain
encore les lois de la république n'était
toujours pas prééminente dans les faits
et après s'être attaqué à tant de
symboles de la république
la prochaine cible des islamistes
pourraient très bien être assise là
parmi nous au sein de cet hémicycle